il en profite pour faire un peu son buzz
en pleine campagne présidentielle parce
que concurrencé par eric zemmour le
rassemblement national a besoin de
montrer qu'il est capable également de
stigmatiser aussi violemment qu'eric
zemmour une partie de la population
heureux les gens à valérie bénaïm vous
ne m'avez pas encore entendu sur la
réalité d'andré vous ne met pas encore
entendu et pourtant vous me renvoyez
comme le dos d'une même pièce avec
jarden bardella mais je n'ai jamais moi
nier les réalités dans ma ville les
réalités liées à la radicalisation
religieuse au départ au djihad joue pas
depuis des années dans ma commune et des
mesures j'en prends depuis des années
avant même d'avoir été maire j'étais
adjoint au maire et je lutte au
quotidien contre la radicalisation
contre l'emprise islamistes par des
actions très concrètes de terrain en
mobilisant les services les associations
de la ville en travaillant étroitement
avec les services de l'état avec la
préfecture mais préfère d'ailleurs l'a
reconnu il y a qu elle il ya un an en
témoignant notre collaboration
exceptionnelle puisque auparavant la
ville de trappes ne travaillez pas avec
les services de l'état c'est le cas
depuis un an depuis que j'ai été élu
maire donc merci avant de juger
d'écouter d'entendre la réalité de ce
que font les acteurs sur lui les uns
sont heureux les gens attrapent et moi
je viens de dire alors je vais faire
sourire il ya eu un classement des
villes où on est les plus heureux oui je
n'avais dans le giron des yvelines et en
ile-de-france et en revanche les trappes
fait partie des villes les mieux placés
dans les yvelines donc pourquoi parce
qu'on a un certain nombre de services
publics parce qu'on a des prestations à
la population un hôpital cancer vexé je
vais vous dire pourquoi je porte plainte
voyez tout rires ça je me sens pas une
affaire de vexations bien sûr c'est
qu'on n'est pas des enfants c'est pour
ces pour les habitants de par la
diffamation c'est quoi c'est quand on
porte atteinte à l'honneur et à la
considération
par exemple en l'occurrence d'une ville
toute entière et ses trente deux mille
habitants et ça a été dit juste avant
trappe c'est une ville comme roubaix
comme d'autres villes en france comme
beaucoup de villes populaires de
banlieue où il ya des difficultés des
réalités contrastées des gens qui
essayent de s'en sortir des populations
d'ailleurs qui pour beaucoup d'entre
elles n'ont pas choisi de venir habiter
la dépopulation issus pour beaucoup de
l'immigration qui n'ont pas choisi de
vivre dans tel ou tel quartier ou dans
tellement de notre territoire jordan
bardella et moi on a un point commun
celui qui disait qu'on se ressemblaient
bah oui quoi pas ça une tête une nuance
en attente de notre peau qui nous
différencie mais il a un enfant
d'immigré italien je suis un enfant
d'immigrés marocains là où se sont
installés à pr neil en première a dit m
sandrine grand grand travail autour de
l'éducation et de la culture elle mène
des projets remarquables justement pour
réussir à intégrer les membres de notre
ville mais quelle que soit leur origine
quand on insulte rentrée 1000 habitants
en dix ans et sa fille vivait dans une
république en dehors de la france et
donc vous n'adhérez pas aux valeurs de
la république eh bien vous venez ça paie
tout notre travail d'intégration mais
c'est le réel qui est erronée des
jordaniens arriver là mais c'est les
réelles qui évoque un essai de phase i
vous avez les choses de manière à vous
étiez content d'être mise en examen pour
cette raison mais c'est une fierté parce
que je vais vous dire qu'ils mènent ou
genre du viagra sans faire cette ut une
concurrence avec eric zemmour c'est quoi
il était entraîneur va laisser
persécutés aujourd'hui que ce soit par
les armes 1 parce que pardon mais les
djihadistes s'en sont pris à des
journalistes ils s'en sont pris à des
policiers ils s'en sont pris et il
menace au quotidien des gens qui dans
ces territoires dans ces quartiers et
même ailleurs remettre en cause
aujourd'hui les pressions du
fondamentalisme islamiste et des des
radicaux les radicaux aujourd'hui ne
vous en déplaise ce qu'ils ont gagné et
voyez moi je fais pas de la politique
chinois défaitiste connaît une année ils
n'ont pas gagné leur a fait d'israël
sera plus fort minutes ali ça fait dix
ans que je me suis engagé politiquement
en seine-saint-denis ça fait plusieurs
années que je suis élu dans ce
département et moi j'ai grandi dans une
cité hlm de seine-saint-denis et dans la
cité hlm de seine saint denis où j'ai
grandi moi tous les jours je voyais de
ma fenêtre d une école coranique privé
avec des gamines de 5,6 en sortir avec
un voile sur les déranger ne vous en
déplaise ça vous dérange je ne vous en
dis ça me dérange parce que je ne vois
pourquoi vous déranger mais parce que
nous sommes en france mais que en france
on n'a pas à voile et les fillettes en
laissant avait su revenir et je vais
même vous dire moins chère julie quand
même l'interdiction du voile dans vos
qualités mais quand vous regarder par la
fenêtre à vous écouter vous est quoi si
vous aimez ça me dérange mais pourquoi
mais ça me dérange et ça des rendez-vous
sont chez nous ont pas déranger le serbe
est en jeu mais ça me dérange et ça
dérange beaucoup de gens et le met juste
quoi c'est pour votre vision d une
question d monsieur non merci ça vous
pose pas de problème cueillez des cafés
où les femmes ne puisse pas rentrer un
souvenez-vous ça avait été pointée à
sevran il y avait un reportage de france
télévisions ont montré que dans des call
tv dont c'est une association
des maires des mères de famille c'était
des monter démonter
comme david des centaines de milliers de
quartier dans notre pays aujourd'hui où
les femmes ne peuvent plus circuler sur
13 heures importunait je vous invite à
boire une bière rue jaurès tout près de
la mairie quand vous voulez mais on ira
boisbouvier vous
extrêmement sérieux et vous ne pouvez
pas fermer les yeux moi je vous fais pas
leurs proches de vous battre tous les
jours contre la radicalisation mais je
dis que j'ai déjà eu plusieurs procès de
ce genre contre des maires de voir l'ue
république islamique c'est mais procède
je les ai tous gagnés parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de mères qui font du
clientélisme et qui pour assurer leur
réélection je crois d'ailleurs que la
première vous avez été élu l'élection à
été annulée et j'étais dans le concert
conventionnel mais avec une obstination
qui a été très basse au commandement
ouais je dis juste et news qu'on est en
train tout à fait aujourd'hui pour
sortir un peu de trappes parce que ce
qu'on voit à trappes on est en train de
le voir partout en france et il ya des
centaines et des centaines de quartiers
aujourd'hui où les femmes ne peuvent
plus circuler sans être importuné ou des
femmes portent le voile parce que porter
le voile c'est l'assurance d'être d'être
tranquille et moi je suis favorable aux
internes ya des drames qui porte loin
des religieux du voile dans l'espace
public mais je considère que ce n'est
rien les jeunes la braguette que je
considère plus loin qu eric zemmour je
considère que le voile est un marqueur
n'ont pu seulement maintenant religieux
un marqueur politique qui marque une
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes et je suis désolé de dire cela
mais je pense que ces marqueurs
religieux qui sont des marqueurs
rigoriste convoi dans des pays musulmans
la france n'est pas l'arabie saoudite la
france ce n'est pas l'iran et quand on
vient en france on vit comme un français
donc moi je pense qu'on peut
parfaitement être issus de l'immigration
aux siens de se sentir pleinement le
pendule
juste
choisir les dates etc dans les pattes
jordan or ces manifestations on est en
train de rêver je vous le dit d'ailleurs
est-ce que vous condamnez le fait que
dans certains bas on ne puissent plus
avoir de femmes aujourd'hui à laisser
leur aide de rentrée est ce que c'est
vraiment essayé que je 4 coiffure mixte
sur 13000 et des enseignants
répondre à lire et vous disiez zéro
maintenant vous dites qu'il n'a
finalement 4 dont ça va on progresse
c'est vous qui l'avez moi je suis pas
vous êtes très bien coiffée j'aimerais
merci pour les coiffeurs de trappes vous
savez vos propos caricaturaux outrancier
et c'est les français qui vivent au
quotidien sur ces territoires ne les
supporte plus parce que ça ne l'est pas
aucune réalité la réalité l'est déjà
assez difficile à vivre des difficultés
à publier à la mélisse djihadisme etc ça
existe et ses délires c'est douloureux
comme ça et j'ai deux ans à nicher les
questionnements par les difficultés pour
les régler les gens comme vous qui
viennent agiter la haine pour le coup
vous ne servez que de carburant à ceux
qui veulent essayer de ap et de
radicaliser une partie de la jeunesse de
notre alliera ben pour moi vous êtes le
carburant principal de ceux qui
justement endoctrinés en brigade des
gamins pour les emmener vers le pirée
vers la haine de la république moi
j'essaye d'une série de deux arrêts mais
la république au crochet rural